hi guys I'm Greg and I'm not Greg this
is Anita star the lovely beautifully
talented Anita star not any of that
Tyrone introduced us and I said only
because she is hot and banging well I do
need up with her that's why people meet
up with me that's the only action
honestly we've talked a lot I remember a
thing people it's just there's my tits
bald I'm so rude are you talking about
Anita I view you as a person
like I said steady don't say that you
know I mean you have a very flat short
that is [ __ ] beautiful ah
we're gonna watch 29 selfies away that's
out of you hard no we're okay 29 hubby
jeezum Nick oh really I feel like some
British people the folky core like
Scottish or another like okay goon King
Kunta filly I got it what tell me twice
what's the [ __ ] twitch this is a
basic sweat twice yeah it's plenty of
[ __ ] i love it because i remember saying
[ __ ] wants to british versus funny and i
would be it's twice they'll be helping
what
Oh Oh
has the baby on the harness that's fun
for camp what it even happening
they cover cell phone jammer I reckon is
better not amendable ah buddy no fire
fire you're having beautiful Oh what's
done oh how sad
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
hmm is way too soon wait that was it
it's a minute and twice you second that
takeaway kid says the ones that disturb
me the most are the ones where they have
kids with them
yeah those poor kids event for children
honestly my mom's a [ __ ] let me look
like I'm gonna have problems and rest of
my life that your Oscars really look at
it a little going around yes do you see
that meme going around where it's like a
picture of your grandma and they compare
like an old picture of a likes of lack
and white typical like grandma's photo
this is a picture of your grandma when
she was young and then they have like in
2020 picture of your grandma it's like a
chick with a snapchat filter puppy-dog
face oh it's not a pic of your grandma
no just me I don't know very
entertaining it was funny because it's
like the new generation you know what I
mean like your generation is 56 I am
going funnier than the grandma like all
I'm gonna no picture of Grandma is the
[ __ ] puppy filter from snapchat on
like a teen space that's a picture of
Grandma okay next there are some stuff
in here that would definitely like to
take like the one with the police
officer pulling you that was fun sup bro
I Eliza
yeah the boy doesn't look he's like what
the [ __ ] you probably got pulled over I
like using his cell phone or something
that's a brilliant selfie that would
make me sad the one with the girl that
was in the hospital yeah did the lady
have to be to their legs up like this is
a regular being rough regularly she just
doesn't give a [ __ ] man she's like I
gotta get this ass shot out Monto if I
want to get [ __ ] tonight you know the
beach is a confusing place for me it can
be have you been to a nude beach
have you yeah do you like it Oh [ __ ]
love it it was amazing
I don't know why I was mainly guys but
most of them work you know okay so it
was cool I thought women are awesome
I didn't really look next time ago I'll
make sure to check out the women for you
very liberating actually I imagine
so so you have to try it it's so
liberating and you're in the ocean and
you're just part of nature and you're
naked and you're just ah this I can't
explain like I like a bit Foley and make
it in the water yeah yeah no I wouldn't
know really though you should check it
out like honestly if you go to Hawaii
there's really nice nude beaches they're
[ __ ] beautiful the ocean is gorgeous
such a like a hippy moment to have with
the earth know I sound beautiful
actually thank you yeah I was it's a
really nice experience a my probably not
staring I have people stare I had some
people of course are you see any of
people are gonna stare yeah no I don't I
don't think I'm seeing it really oh yeah
very creepy [ __ ] if you at all I
admire your body when you're not looking
really yeah because that's normal
sometimes are you changing you don't
know them they're like it's this part of
my life right actually at my environment
or yeah actually I your apartment okay
when you go to use about I'm gonna go
this will be my last course why I'm just
kidding I do the same thing like sneak
in a year please thank you you're
welcome
I uh I noticed yeah I'm on ok right we
noticed and that's our recreation of our
first conversation when we officially
talked after spying on each other yes it
was a good moment for me I don't know
improve so what's for you or not but you
know the male body there's just
something beautiful about soft pink just
hang this sad sad little guy shriveled
you want to cuddle it thank you so
animal you just want to make coffee
just be happy walkers do you have enough
of me you didn't you made me
uncomfortable you officially you
officially like you made me
uncomfortable of what I did this is the
kind of stuff you we talk about when non
movie related you know this is like
whatever conversation I mean
people said we should react anything
should be in a moment
just let it happen for those who made it
this far in the video this channels like
you know meet people halfway I mainly
like to talk about movies and stuff but
there are a lot of people who subscribe
because they want to see like reactions
like these kind of yeah yes I know like
every once in a while guys in the week
he's got a hello in my it is what I want
the man yeah yeah we had to subscribe or
just here was you can help them
happening scriber the real region
subscribe to the real a reject I need a
star is the star I'm not you any world
honey is the best but I mean I'm like
you know if you feel sorry for me so I'm
going channel and wholly part of it
don't go to her challenge because you
feel sorry for her please go to your
channel meet validation is it that hot
actually happened alright never mind
don't go to my channel yeah then we cut
the camera